[Musique]
je suis Hervé Georget responsable du
cirque Georget ici même à luine et je
suis l'aîné de la 2è génération le
cirque georger est une famille un peu
atypique puisque mon père était
menuisier ma mère était couturière et
par pion par l'art de la magie ils ont
créé leur propre établissement il y a
aujourd'hui un peu plus de 42 ans
aujourd'hui nous avons cette 3è
génération qui qui commence aussi dans
la piste ils sont quatre onmon ça oui et
on fait passer notre ami
ukrainien c'est avant tout une passion
et c'est vrai queaujourd'hui arriver en
2024 et vivre de sa passion c'est je
pense une des meilleures
récompenses il faut savoir tout faire
puisqueura d'abord que le CIRC AR il
vend est chauffeur fautir conduire ses
camions monteur de chapitaux n avons
bien sûr installé tous les gradins que
vous avez tout autour recruter les
artistes monter le spectacle régler les
lumières toute la partie aussi
administrative c'est une entreprise
comme comme une autre le CIRC
aujourd'hui et puis tout doit être
prêt l' soire de spectacle et bien on va
V tous les vêtements se mettre les beaux
costumes et là on va se transformer en
Monsieur Loyal pour ce qui est de ma
part à moi en tout
[Musique]
et pour mettre en valeur toutes ces
artistes qui ont des heures et des
heures d'entraînement derrière eux pour
pour remettre des paillettes dans les
yeux du public